josef cap willkommen zu einem neuen
video leute ich bin so heißt ihr habt
den titel gesehen erst mal eine gewisse
vorgeschichte dazu käme eine kleine
schwester wohl schon ewigkeiten switch
haben ich hab mir gerade noch mal drüber
geredet aber bei uns zu hause das so
dass die eltern ein bisschen kritisch
sind versteht man bekommt nicht
unbedingt nur so spielkonsolen oder so
einfach so und deswegen werde ich heute
meine kleine schwester franken aber
positiv prenger nicht dass ich irgendwie
negativ wie positiv erachten ich hab mir
gesagt ist jetzt im media markt
einkaufen rasierer was ich vielleicht
auch machen werde aber zusätzlich werde
ich wenn ich nach hause komme einem
tennismatch mit spielen für meine kleine
schwester dabei haben und leute ich bin
soweit ist könnt ihr euch wirklich nicht
vorstellen wie zwei ich bin als älteste
kind von unserer es gibt mich max mit
schwester marie keine straßenbahn neun
jahre jünger als ich bin im alter wo man
ihm kein geld verdienen so was so weit
weg ist von ganz ehrlich was ich dafür
gegeben als ich so jung war für den
größeren bruder der mir einfach mal
sowas kauft etwas gegönnt hätte weil
meine eltern wirklich gegönnt hätte wir
haben wir das gehört verboten
ob wir heute fakt folgendermaßen ich war
gerade in von gewinn und die haben die
swiss in diesem medium machen nicht wir
machen zweiten bei uns nicht statt in
ruhiges machen
media markt preis keine versteckten
kosten
magath im media markt im anliegen mit
kaufen zu wollen haben wie vor wichtig
der zweite markt hat auch keine zusätze
wie weit noch einen dritten der 3 vor
drei minuten die letzte raus ich fühle
mich leute alle media märkte im weiteren
unfall haben die switch nicht mehr was
man jetzt ich hab keinen bock zu warten
heute das muss jetzt heute passieren ich
bin sportler muss heute geschehen
heute kriegt meine schwester eine
überraschung auf jeden fall heute aber
rabatte seeleute und zwar haben aber
auch andere sachen von nintendo
diskutiert und war über einen 3ds xl ich
glaube so ein hatte meine schwester
schon mal eine freude von ihr oder seid
noch nicht genau den aber kaputt gemacht
wir haben wir schon länger kein mehr und
will auch so ein unbedingt kam deswegen
würde ich sagen machen wir einfach aus
dem tritt bringt ein 3 d f frank herzer
ein und holen 3ds geht die spurensuche
[Musik]
einkaufen so weit ich bin echt gespannt
wie meine kleine schwester reagieren
wird den riesig gespannt wer gesehen wir
haben
folgender marken wie wird meine
schwester hat er heute nämlich schon
erzählt dass ich gerne mit ihr aufnehmen
wenn aber sie denke ich mir in meiner
schwester bewertet youtuber mit ihr
aufnehmen
dass ich jetzt sicher der fall und
deswegen weiß nicht zeigen möchte weil
hier reingehen und überlassen
hallo ich werde direkt mal ein video mit
ihr aufnehmen kannst du schon mal die
dings anziehen die maske ich mache aber
anfangs kleinen block ich sagte oh ich
bin gerade zurück vom mediamarkt den
rasierer bekommen und dass meine
schwester dann setzte es damit direkt
auch so vom verein aufzunehmen okay du
bewertet youtube auch das zubehör
schaden auszubessern
das ist die stelle ist der bsv
das sieht ja mit dem coolsten anzahl
gerade seine gäste da und dahin geht
doch noch
ich habe den falschen größe sind
tatsächlich eingeholte funktioniert das
meiste noch mal was gesagt wenig davon
erfährt
ich hab ich nicht wir machen es geheim
insgeheim wo wir haben da kann die
ersten wieder okay das werk im müll
geworfen
ich verabschiede mich so weiß heute
keiner von euch dass das eben möglich